we saw that two sets are equivalent if
their cardinal numbers are the same but
when are two sets equal two sets are
equal when they have precisely the same
elements you will soon know what I mean
when I say
precisely consider these two sets set e
has 1 2 and three as its elements and
set F also has 1 2 and three as it
elements since they have the same
elements we can say that set e is equal
to set
F now consider two other sets set G with
3 9 and 11 as its elements and set H
with 11 3 and 9 as its
elements we can see that both the sets
have the same three elements 3 9 and 11
so set G is equal to set h
from this example we could say that as
long as the elements in the sets are the
same the order does not matter now look
at these two sets set I consists of four
5 and 8 set J consists of 4 5 8 and 9 If
You observe you can see that both the
sets have 4 5 and 8 as their elements
but J also has nine which set I does not
have
this means that I is not equal to J
remember for sets to be equal their
cardinal numbers also have to be the
same in this case n of I is not equal to
n of J which makes the sets unequal when
I say precisely this is what I meant
same elements and the same number of
elements now look at these two pair of
sets which are equal cardinal number of
e is equal to the Cardinal number of f
Cardinal number of G is equal to the
Cardinal number of H remember two sets
that are equal will always be
equivalent now look at sets e and H they
are equivalent but since the elements
are not the same they are not
equal but now look at sets E and F they
are equivalent but they're also
equal this tells us that two sets that
are equivalent may or may not be equal
remember two sets are equivalent if they
have the same Cardinal number and two
sets are equal if they have the same
Cardinal number and the same
[Music]
elements